hey conan here and this is my video
response uh to mr technical difficult
uh this video uh how to lose something
up your nose um
i have a concern i watch the video
and a chilling thought occurred to me
what if
this video
starts to encourage
other young people
to tape themselves
doing things that are asinine or foolish
and then they start to post those on the
internet
and that becomes a trend what if
people start
taking videos of
i don't know household animals cats
whatever doing silly things or
embarrassing things and what if god
forbid someday
this even led to
some kind of pornography i may be
getting ahead of myself let's nip this
in the butt the internet has a very
limited bandwidth
and really its primary function
is to
communicate a signal if there's an
emergency the internet's such a
beautiful
simple small
just basically a telephone
uh
communication device let's just leave it
the way it is
and uh let's avoid this potentially
dark
uh hideous future
that's my plea
please subscribe to my channel